nature provides
all the food we eat
the water we drink
and the oxygen we breathe
it gives us life
it is beautiful
but it is also
fragile
i was reminded of this in july
when i went into space with blue origin
i was told that seeing the earth from
space
changes the lens
through which you view the world
but i was not prepared
for just how much
that would be true
looking back at earth from up there
the atmosphere seems so
thin
the world
so finite and so fragile
now
in this critical year
and what we all know is the decisive
decade
we must all stand together to protect
our world
climate change gives us a powerful
reason to invest in nature each year
forests and landscapes absorb 11
billion tons of co2 from the atmosphere
helping to slow climate change
as we destroy nature we reverse this
process
cut down a forest
destroy the mangroves
pave over the prairies
and instead of sequestering carbon we
emit it
in too many parts of the world
nature is already flipping
from a carbon sink to a carbon source
this is a profound and urgent danger to
us all
that's why last month in new york
nine philanthropic organizations
announced an additional five billion
dollars to support the goal of thirty by
thirty to protect thirty percent of all
land and sea by twenty thirty
i was honored to be a part of this with
a one billion dollar pledge from the
bezos earth fund
and today
i'm pleased to announce a two billion
dollar pledge allocated directly to
restoring nature and transforming food
systems
this is part of the bezos earth fund's
10 billion dollar commitment to fight
climate change
enhance nature
and advance environmental justice and
economic opportunity
together this three billion dollars in
pledges will drive a new three-fold
nature agenda for the bezos earth fund
focused simultaneously on conservation
restoration and food transformation
we must conserve what we still have
we must restore what we've lost
and we must grow what we need to live
without degrading the planet for future
generations to come
in the atmosphere molecules of carbon
dioxide cause climate change
and risk destroying life as we know it
but bring that carbon back down to earth
through the magic of photosynthesis into
trees plants crops and soil
and this brings life and vitality
today
two-thirds of the land in africa is
degraded
but this can be reversed
restoration can improve soil fertility
raise yields and improve food security
make water more reliable
create jobs and boost economic growth
while also sequestering carbon
continent-wide initiatives
like africa 100 and the great green wall
offer significant hope
they must now be scaled up
ahead of cop 27 next year the bezos
earth fund would be eager to participate
in a concerted strategy
led by african nations
to seriously and effectively ramp up
support for restoration on the continent
however we cannot rely
only on governments ngos and
philanthropies to solve the climate
crisis
the private sector must also play its
part to reduce carbon emissions
companies need to take leadership
positions
amazon has co-founded the climate pledge
with christianity figures
and set a goal to reach net zero carbon
by 2040
10 years ahead of the paris agreement
goals
as part of this pledge
amazon aims to power all its operations
with 100 renewable energy by 2025
and is working to convert its delivery
fleet to electric vehicles
amazon is inviting other companies to
join the climate pledge and more than
200 have to date
companies can also lead the way on
nature-based solutions
over the past six months amazon
partnered with leading companies
countries committed to protecting the
tropical forests and the gov their
tropical forests and the governments of
norway the uk and the us to mobilize an
unprecedented level of funding
to fight tropical deforestation
through an initiative called the leaf
coalition
amazon has committed significant
financial support for leaf and the
coalition will be signing letters of
intent with governments that are ready
to receive support